après deux ans de pause le festival du
film de québec a mis la main sur une
vedette pour sa onzième année
d'existence au diamant le cinéaste
oliver stone controverse assuré mais
aussi un vaste répertoire c'est
phénoménal comme you marqué par son
travail plusieurs époques ces films ont
aussi marqué des grands changements dans
la culture populaire et la culture mame
politique américaine avec avec les
débloquer suscité son film jfq oliver
stone a rencontré les journalistes en
compagnie de l'historien james eu deux
géniaux dont les recherches l'ont
persuadé de faire une suite à son
célèbre film de 1991 gfk revisited
contient de nouvelles révélations et des
preuves
ainsi ce n'est pas le cerveau du
président qu'on voit sur les photos il
était trop endommagée par un tir croisé
la magic boulet que lee enlever aux
world aurait tiré seul n'a jamais existé
bref le rapport warren c'est un tissu de
mensonges
alors qui a tué gfk
de travail
et pourquoi l'assassiner les deux hommes
sont catégoriques john kennedy voulait
changer le monde et instaurer la paix
avec l'union soviétique en afrique avec
cuba des intérêts puissants voulait l'en
empêcher c'est leur théorie
ce n'était pas le sujet mais oliver
stone at il perdu le respect qu'il avait
pour vladimir poutine depuis son
entrevue fleuve de 2017 et après
l'invasion de l'ukraine qu'il a
clairement condamné sur twitter ils
répondent plutôt ceci pour
deux raisons
oliver stone provocateur empêcheurs de
tourner en rond metteur de bâtons dans
les roues va-t-il continuer non si ça
marche pourquoi je mets un boeuf
pourquoi je mettrais un bateau non si ça
marche ça marche c'est bien si ça marche
mais si ça devient dangereux pour le
monde il faut mettre vous allez
continuer
de sauver le monde de
jean michel leprince sera du canada
québec
merci